>> Greg: EIGHT NO PARTY LIKE A
DONNER PARTY.
YEAH, ONE OF JEFFREY DONNA'S
WORST CRIMES IS A RECIPE OVER AT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
A RECENT "NEW YORK TIMES" PIECE
DELVES INTO THE GROWING TREND OF
CANNIBALISM IN CONTEMPORARY
FICTION.
YOU KNOW I LOVE CONTEMPORARY
FICTION, THAT'S WHY READ
BRIAN KILMEADE'S BOOKS.
HE'S IN BED ALREADY.
THE TREND INCLUDES A SLEW OF NEW
MOVIES, NOVELS, AND TV SHOWS
FEATURING HUMANS FEASTING ON
EACH OTHER AND OFTEN
ROMANTICIZED FASHION.
I BET MICHAEL MOORE TASTES LIKE
FOIE GRAS.
IN OTHER WORDS, NOT PURELY FOR
SURVIVAL, WHICH IS THE EXCUSE
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN USING.
AUDIENCES SEEM TO BE CRAVING IT
APPARENTLY.
ONE OF THE COCREATORS OF
"YELLOW JACKETS," SHORT ANSWERS
ABOUT TEEN GIRLS EATING EACH
OTHER, EXPLAINED THAT WE ARE
OFTEN DRAWN TO THE THINGS THAT
REPULSE US MOST.
THAT'S HOW I GOT MARRIED.
AND THAT'S WHY AM FRIENDS WITH
HIM.
IMAGINE EATING HIM.
THERE'S MORE FLAVOR AND CREAMED
TOFU.
ALONG WITH THE FICTIONALIZED
TELLINGS OF HUMAN CONSUMPTION,
THE TIMES ALSO HIGHLIGHT THE
MANY HISTORICAL ACCOUNTS OF REAL
CANNIBALISM.
THE ARTICLE CAUGHT MAJOR FLAK
ONLINE FOR NORMALIZING
CANNIBALISM.
OF COURSE MANY CLAIMED THAT THE
PRESS IS THE ENEMY OF THE
PEOPLE.
NOW I KNOW IT'S BECAUSE WE
LOOKED DELICIOUS.
TOM.
I FIGURED YOU WOULD KNOW THE
ANSWER TO THIS.
WHAT SITUATION IS THE CUT OFF OR
WHERE YOU CAN CONTEMPLATE
CANNIBALISM GIMMICK WHAT IF
YOU'RE STUCK IN AN ELEVATOR FOR
LIKE FOUR HOURS?
>> NO, I DON'T THINK -- ELEVATOR
IS NO GOOD BECAUSE THERE'S FOOD
RIGHT OUTSIDE THE ELEVATOR.
YOU'VE GOT TO BE OFF ON THE WILD
SOMEWHERE LIKE THE CLASSIC IF
YOU ARE IN A BOAT AND THEN
YOU'VE GOT -- YOU KNOW, YOU'VE
GOT TO DRAW STRAWS, DECIDE WE
ARE GOING TO EAT.
I THINK I WOULD BE DELICIOUS
THOUGH.
>> Greg: WHY?
BECAUSE IT'S ALL WHITE MEAT?
RACIST.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THE BEST WINGS, I DON'T KNOW.
BUT WE'VE ALWAYS LIKED
CANNIBALISM.
WE HAVE SWING GREEN IN OUR
GENERATION.
AND THEN WE HAD -- WHAT ABOUT
THE OTHER THING ABOUT EATING
PEOPLE?
THAT HANNIBAL LECTOR.
WE ALL LOVED THAT.
WE LOVE EATING PEOPLE.
WE THINK IT'S GREAT.
>> Greg: DO WE REALLY?
>> WHAT I'M SAYING IS THE SHOW
IS NOTHING NEW, EVERY GENERATION
HAS THEIR "LET'S EAT PEOPLE"
SHOW.
>> Greg: IT REMINDED ME, JOHN,
CNN HAD A HOST, DEAR MEMBER
THAT?
WHEN HE ATE HUMAN BRAINS ON CNN
IN A DOCUMENTARY?
IT JUST SHOWS YOU THAT CNN NEVER
WATCHED THEIR OWN STUFF.
IT WENT AROUND WITH SOME KIND OF
ECCENTRIC CALLED AND ACTUALLY
ATE HUMAN BRAINS AND I THINK IT
WAS THE LAST EPISODE THEY DID.
>> I WOULD HOPE SO.
>> Greg: IF THE ONLY TIME IT
CNN THEY ACTUALLY HAD BRAINS ON
THE AIR.
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
I CAME UP WITH THAT JUST NOW!
TAKE THAT, AMERICA!
DOES CANNIBALISM DESERVE THIS
STIGMA, JOHN?
AND HAVE YOU EVER THOUGHT THAT
YOU WOULD BE ASKED THAT
QUESTION?
>> NO, I DIDN'T.
I THINK IT'S VERY UNFAIR TO THE
CANNIBAL LISTS.
THEY ARE A LARGE SECTOR OF THE
DEMOCRAT BASE AND ANY TO BE
CAREFUL HOW THEY TALK TO THEM.
WHAT ABOUT THE WHOLE THING ABOUT
YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO EAT MEAT?
>> Greg: YES, RIGHT, AS A
VEGAN, YOU CAN'T BE A CANNIBAL.
>> SO THAT CANCELS THEM OUT OF
THE GATE.
"NEW YORK TIMES," THERE'S A LOT
OF VEGANS.
DID A VEGAN WRITE THAT ARTICLE?
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW.
IN THE MIND OF
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," IT'S
PROBABLY MORE HUMANE TO EAT A
HUMAN BEING THAN AN ANIMAL,
RIGHT?
BECAUSE WE ARE OPPRESSORS,
WE ARE OPPRESSED PEOPLE, RIGHT,
KAT GIMMICK YOU ARE OPPRESSING
ME RIGHT NOW.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE I CAN DO THAT
WITHOUT SAYING ANYTHING.
I'M SO POWERFUL.
I CAN'T GET ALL WOUND UP ABOUT
THIS ARTICLE.
FOR MY 20TH BIRTHDAY I DID THROW
MYSELF AT DAHMER PARTY THEMED
BIRTHDAY PARTY.
I CALLED OF THE DONNER PARTY
PARTY.
AND I WISH I HAD THOUGHT ABOUT
IT EARLIER BECAUSE I DO HAVE
PHOTOS.
WE HAD BONNETS AND SEVERED LIMBS
AND WE WERE AT A BAR.
IT WAS GREAT.
BUT THIS ARTICLE WAS JUST
TALKING ABOUT HOW THERE'S MOVIES
AND BOOKS ABOUT CANNIBALISM.
BUT I ACTUALLY DO THINK THIS
STIGMA IS A LITTLE BIT TOO HIGH.
>> Greg: REALLY?
>> YEAH.
THE DONNER PARTY DIDN'T WANT TO
EACH OTHER.
HE DIDN'T HAVE A CHOICE.
AND IF I'M DEAD, YOU GUYS CAN
EAT ME, I DON'T CARE.
>> Greg: YOU ARE ALWAYS REALLY
CHARITABLE.
>> YEAH.
>> Greg: SHE IS VERY SKINNY,
IF YOU REALLY BELIEVE THAT YOU
WOULD GAIN SOME WEIGHT SO IT
WOULD BE A BIGGER MEAL.
>> THIS IS ONE WAY TO LOWER OUR
CARBON FOOTPRINT.
>> Greg: IT REALLY IS.
>> THE ONE WOMAN SAID WE ARE
DRAWN TO THINGS THAT REPULSE US
MOST.
IF THAT WAS REALLY TRUE, THEN
FULL FRONTAL WITH SAMANTHA BE
WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN CANCELED.
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: WORKING A JAB IN
THERE.
I LOVE THE STORY OF THE DONNER
PARTY BECAUSE WE USED TO ALWAYS
DRIVE FROM SAN MATEO TO
LAKE TAHOE AND YOU HAVE TO GO
THROUGH DONNER PASS AND MY
PARENTS WOULD SCARE US TELLING
THAT STORY.
THEY ACTUALLY CUT UP ALL THE
PARTS AND WRAP THEM IN PAPER SO
YOU DIDN'T KNOW WHO YOU WERE
EATING AND THEN YOU WOULD HAVE
TO PICK IT OUT LIKE THAT?
ISN'T THAT GREAT?
>> SOUNDS LIKE YOU STUDIED IT.
>> I THINK THAT'S GREAT, I THINK
THAT'S REALLY NICE.
>> Greg: THANK YOU!
>> I THINK THAT'S VERY SWEET.
I WOULDN'T WANT TO KNOW WHO I
WAS EATING SO IF YOU DON'T KNOW
WHAT IS -- YEAH, THAT WAS VERY
SWEET.
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK THE
SEGMENT IS GOING TO BE FLIPPED
FOR FOX.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO GO "GO TO
THE WEBSITE INTO THE CANNIBALISM
SEGMENT."
>> THEY WILL LEAD WITH IT ON
"FOX & FRIENDS."
>> Greg: THIS WILL SHOW UP ON
FOX & FRIENDS WE CAN.
>> HOW LONG BEFORE IT IS A FOX
PATIENT SHOW?
>> Greg: IT'S AN EIGHT PART
SERIES.
EIGHT, GET IT?